oh you didn't move your stuff to ship
before the crash oh yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
so did you guys hear about FTX yes
gigantic crypto exchange freaking crazy
meltdown City meltdown so what happened
what's the deal well it looks like uh
the [ __ ] leverage Traders
the Geniuses crashed it at FTX well they
were just they were taking
um customer funds and then playing
[ __ ] leverage games with it they lost
and then the funds draft they have no
liquidity and now
um people who are using their exchange
like I want my money in there's a
there's a run on on that and they're
saying we can't sorry we can't settle we
can't settle and now there's nowhere to
go and they're insolvent and they're
they filed for chapter 11. Tom Brady and
Larry David are being sued because they
were part of FTX as far as Like Larry
David they had the commercial in the
Super Bowl right oh exactly did you see
Kevin O'Leary he was um there's a clip
of him going around saying like that's
probably the most safest thing that you
could bet on crypto right now this was
during the the pump he verbally backed
it up yeah he he said this is the place
to be but at the time though with how
deep they were connected with officials
in politics and all that you would think
it's like Ben it's backed by our
government all this stuff it's gonna be
okay Steph Curry said it's okay all this
[ __ ] came out right after the crash it's
been pretty crazy like I'm just I'm just
mind blown how many people are connected
to it well it's funny too because they
blame krypton's like dude these are
[ __ ] d-gen [ __ ] like like the
idea that that Bitcoin and like that the
the blockchain is at fault for this is
wild yeah but non-sentient beings are at
fault you know what I mean blamed
algorithm yeah Don Cheadle from Space
Jam blame the graphics card it's those
damn smart contracts you know your
permissionless to transact with each
other and then right after this too I
remember right after it happens I get
this uh generic email y'all y'all
probably got it too from binance that
it's like you know like blah the crypto
space of all this is what we're doing
with your funds nobody over trades no
we're not trading with anybody's
customers funds you know and it's just
putting it blatantly out there because
this isn't the first time a large chain
or organization or or whatever has done
this you know what I mean like the
amount of times that a site or or what
an exchange will take customer funds and
then leverage it out in order to try to
make other profits without the customers
knowing like that's happened many times
by the way that's what banks do yeah
that's what banks do but it throws over
around the banks it would be a [ __ ]
nightmare that's the point of banks
right no they'll just get bailed out
well they'll of course but exactly
but that's what happened during the 2008
crash is all the small uh Banks I mean
we don't see Washington Mutual anymore
remember that one yeah
they turned into chase you know what's
cool is the I didn't learn before about
the history between CZ and uh Sam
backman oh what was the history so cz's
the owner of binance and he was right
about to buy FTX but what happened like
I guess that they they used to like kind
of be friends and they were working
together and then they had a falling out
and [ __ ] and then when they had separate
things going on uh Sam bankman
eventually came to him and asked for the
bailout and then he he went and instead
of bailing him out he he basically did
an analysis and then publicly said I'm
not gonna do that because these guys are
pulling some [ __ ] well prior to this and
it buried them CZ took a bunch of ftt
which is ftx's like exchange token and
he moved it and basically
um similar to the market like we're
gonna sell this to cover our positions
and then
um he made sandbagman freed release of
public statement basically saying like
Hey we're going to work with binance and
he like bent the need of binance and CZ
like because CZ played him real hard is
what everyone's saying right because
right I'm gonna sell all of this AKA
tank your [ __ ] token and AKA help
tank help to start a trigger to tank
your exchange and then
um SPF releases this public statement
like we actually got with CZ we're
really happy we're working yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah beautiful we're
gonna cover everybody who's like got
money on the exchange don't worry you'll
get paid out and then CZ gotta look at
the books and then he's like oh I see
[ __ ] tons of debt I'm out [ __ ] you
and then um told the public he's not
bailing him out and then it was just
[ __ ] blast off as far well in the
opposite direction that's why everyone's
calling CZ like Dad he's cold he's a
gangster dude he's a gangster I mean he
he did a smart move yeah you know what I
mean um and took out his competition
yeah and SBF also like he [ __ ] up you
know what I mean oh yeah so it's it's
not so much like he's a gangster like
he's an [ __ ] cold-hearted
[ __ ] but he's like a damn he's a
cold hard [ __ ] you know what I mean
that's cool did you see that how they
were laundering um the funds through
Ukraine and that's why he was FTX was
donating so much to the DNC well he was
joining he was joining a lot to the DNC
under the offices of I'm going to get
favor with regulatory environment right
but then now it's revealed that they
were FTX was setting up donations to
Ukraine and then though that money was
getting sent back to the DNC they're
actually the number two they're just
washing it yeah they're the number two
contributor to the DNC so Ukraine isn't
getting the money that we donated it's
going like you know how they got a ton
in Bitcoin they just washed it through
FTX and and that went right back to the
Democratic campaigns oh my God the Dems
didn't tell us that though
that's not even something that's like
Joe's it's like alleged and like it's
not confirmed yes this is like [ __ ] that
they were doing like they were actually
sending this money to Ukraine and then
Ukraine and then the the money was being
used being fully rebated and by the way
I'm non-partisan I'm just
anti-corruption and the Republicans done
done this [ __ ] too so it's not it's
right and left yeah this is a game
that's played yes of course either
either one who plays it it when there's
a proxy war they say let's save this
country let's donate money gets sent
over there how much of that goes to the
actual citizens to help support that or
the troops or whatever it goes to the
U.S military industrial complex we're
spending um 100 bucks on Lobster nights
which the soldiers should should have
yeah
they should get some
yeah good for them right surf and turf
Saturdays yeah but then um when Raytheon
charges a couple hundred dollars for a
screw that the American public has to
pay oh that's a good screw or a crab
claw opener yeah
do you know a lot about
um the stuff between SPF and Alameda
research so Alameda research was helping
to fund offshoots of FTX right so
they're have a whole gigantic huge
ecosystem that was that was being
they're allocating funds
for all kinds of different stuff
including Solana because something
happened where he transferred 10 billion
to Alameda research and then 2 billion
went like missing
there's a there's a lot being
uncomfortable right now I'm not familiar
exactly well missing everything I can't
I can't I just remember putting together
a bunch of stuff from Jake trans video
and I was like oh well that sounds
[ __ ] crazy so they helped to fund
Solana if you remember like Solana
Solana went from a hugely underheard of
project to like one of the biggest
pumped things like during the bull
market and the The Entity behind that
was FTX and Alameda like they were
pumping that entire ecosystem fumbling
cash through it and that's not nefarious
that's like oh that means it's evil or
whatever they were building out Solana
and now Solana has a huge like Dev crew
for it like tons of developers are
building apps for it in depth for it
right but that that doesn't
um bode well for what just happened like
it it's basically a sieve got taken to
this whole thing oh so we'll see what
happens it's like a bunch of questions
really like it's kind of like what
happened with Luna right like it's like
we we what's a little different because
SPF like got caught with his hand in the
cookie jar like we can see what happened
right whereas with dokwan and Luna
there's a lot of conjecturing about
wallets that you know people I don't
think who actually read about this stuff
like in a non-normy way
can can really justify like like saying
that oh this cuecoin account was
definitely do quons like they don't
[ __ ] know that that's the weird
things there's such little definitive
stuff and every day they're saying don't
Quan's being arrested now here like all
these different stories and nothing ever
happens nothing happens but then here
like Sam bagman feeds straight up
tweeted I [ __ ] up yeah that's for such
a difference yeah just tell us what's
gonna happen to our shib
uh it's over all right sorry did you see
the was it the New York Post or the
Washington Post article there was
nothing about all of the
you know insider trading the corruption
there was nothing about that yeah I'm
not surprised that's why I'm like was it
because of the the the
he had with the DNC well we'll find out
because and the SEC if he doesn't get
charged they're all friends right it'll
be same as it ever was right right
because I think when you're too embedded
with the government they have to cover
their own Tracks Of course and they
don't want to look stupid so I think oh
yeah that kind of
protects you if you're invested so much
into
[ __ ] with the government and then if
you're like investigated they're like oh
no no no this is true but if you're this
public facing and you're taking pictures
of Tom Brady and Larry David they're all
in the commercials and like I think this
could be a little bit different like
where it's like don't they have to face
accountability for how visible they've
been FTX Arena the Miami Heat stadium
like had the [ __ ] FTX logo on the top
but it still has it still has it they're
removing it Bang Bros sent a bid to take
it over I think I think the question is
who's going to hold them accountable
because like we can the public can be
like upset but what about like the whole
Epstein thing what about like you know
you can't have the people that's
supposed to keep them accountable like
also in bed with them I know what you
mean yeah I mean
if a three-letter agency like FBI
whatever comes after them then I feel
like oh [ __ ] this is really serious
there's some internal going fighting
going on in Washington right yeah
they'll find some way to pinpoint a Fall
Guy I think like in these departments
It's gotta be SPF though yeah it'll just
be a fall guy or his girlfriend did you
guys see that video that's so [ __ ]
hilarious I love that she's talking
about like oh like I don't really like I
trade but I don't really use stop losses
I think that's kind of like [ __ ]
whack
like we don't really think that that's
necessary they really need a math degree
it is
so hey that's cool I mean but the funny
thing is no matter what they're caught
saying at this point it's just gonna be
stupid because of the result right yeah
so it's like there's no good interview I
love it when people are like this high
and they [ __ ] know everything and it
[ __ ] slam dunks on them yeah we all
we all take our dunks every now and then
we got dunked on this year we sure did
it was a hell of a ride I love a ride oh
you didn't move your stuff to ship
before the crash oh yeah
oh yeah and then I was like
the FTX Arena they are taking the STX
name away from it and bang Bros did
submit like a 10 million dollar bid or
something to be uh Bang Bros Arena and
everyone thought they were joking but
they were like no that's our real name
he might do it dude dude what I wouldn't
give for like [ __ ] from Bang Bros
Arena
yeah dude trying to think of a Jimmy
Butler pun
best thing about this loud well you have
to find silver linings right
Woo's biggest [ __ ] competitor is FTA
yeah let's go
[Applause]
laughs